Tasha: 到门口了
Tasha: We're at the door.
Tasha: 用不用
Tasha: Do we need to?
Katrina:  昨天的这些旧的是不是可以删掉了
Katrina: Can we delete these old ones from yesterday?
Jake: 呀对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Katrina:  那他一会别又
Katrina: So that he won't...
Jake: 对眼线都删掉才可以
Jake: Yes, we have to delete all the eyeliners first.
Jake: 让一下
Jake: Excuse me.
Jake: 我要扫一下
Jake: I need to sweep a bit.
Lucia: 嗯啊sorry
Lucia: Oh, sorry.
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: It's okay, no problem.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 请坐
Jake: Please sit.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Shure:  然后这样他们的时间码就对上了是吗
Shure: So, does this mean their timestamps will match?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  可以啊
Shure: Okay, cool.
Jake: okay一楼的就好了
Jake: Okay, the first floor is done.
Shure:  想想咱们烤肉今天要买什么
Shure: Think about what we need to buy for the barbecue today.
Jake: 你歇歇
Jake: You take a break.
Shure:  我可我可要把我祖传的手艺拿出来了
Shure: No way, I need to bring out my family's secret recipe.
Jake: 你可以在那什么美团里也买一点
Jake: You can also buy some stuff from Meituan.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Shure:  我们家传到我这边已经是第17代了
Shure: My family has passed it down for 17 generations.
Shure:  楼上楼下
Shure: Upstairs or downstairs?
Jake: 放
Jake: Put it...
Jake: 先放楼下吧
Jake: Put it downstairs first.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 妈呀这网好差呀
Lucia: Oh my, this internet is so bad.
Alice: 查小红书的时候
Alice: When I was checking Little Red Book...
Alice: 他给我推了一些奇怪的内容
Alice: It recommended some weird stuff to me.
Alice: 我还点进去看了
Alice: And I clicked on it.
Alice: 我觉得很社死怎么办
Alice: I feel so socially dead, what do I do?
Alice: 还录下来了
Alice: And it recorded it.
Alice: 哈哈哈无所谓吧
Alice: Hahaha, never mind.
Lucia: 应该他们会处理吧
Lucia: They should handle it, right?
Alice: 无所谓喽
Alice: Whatever.
Lucia: 没事我觉得我们打开社交软件时候
Lucia: It's fine, I think when we open social media...
Lucia: 肯定会出现各种
Lucia: All sorts of things will pop up.
Alice: 巨尴尬无比的东西哈哈哈
Alice: Super awkward stuff, hahaha.
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Shure:  哦哦我们是活动
Shure: Oh, oh, we have an activity.
Shure:  还有交换礼物的活动是吗
Shure: Is there a gift exchange activity too?
Shure:  是要带着礼物上去吗
Shure: Do we need to bring the gifts up?
Tasha: 啊先不用了  啊好
Tasha: Ah, not yet. Ah, okay.
Shure:   好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina:  品尝饮料
Katrina: Tasting drinks.
Shure:  哎呦完了
Shure: Oh no, I'm done for.
Shure:  我刚喝完咖啡
Shure: I just had coffee.
Shure:  喝不出来
Shure: I can't taste anything.
Katrina:  我也是
Katrina: Me too.
Shure:  一会漱一下口吧
Shure: Let's rinse our mouths later.
Lucia: 品尝饮料
Lucia: Tasting drinks.
Lucia: 饮料好像已经快被我们喝光了
Lucia: The drinks are almost finished by us.
Lucia: 我记得
Lucia: I remember.
Tasha: 还有存货
Tasha: There's more in stock.
Katrina:  天呐感觉有那个魔鬼料理
Katrina: Oh my god, it feels like there's that devilish food.
Shure:  漱我口
Shure: Rinse my mouth.
Alice: 呃那那我等你吧
Alice: Uh, then I'll wait for you.
Jake: 礼物一会再拿
Jake: We'll get the gifts later.
Jake: 喝完这个排完名之后再拿
Jake: After we finish this and rank them.
Alice: 那要特别急的话我就选择叫你
Alice: If it's urgent, I'll call you.
Lucia: 对哦就是很急
Lucia: Yes, it's really urgent.
Lucia: 你上去了吧
Lucia: Did you go up?
Katrina:  我靠他居然能敷上去
Katrina: Wow, he actually managed to apply it.
Katrina:  哇哈哈有点急
Katrina: Haha, it's a bit urgent.
Alice: 这个让我的花花面对着你
Alice: Let my flower face you.
Tasha: 然后从每个杯子里尝出不同的水
Tasha: Then taste the different waters from each cup.
Jake: yes
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 不会吧
Lucia: No way.
Shure:  怡宝我肯定一眼能尝出来
Shure: I can definitely recognize Yibao at a glance.
Alice: 我要把我花花对着
Alice: I want to face my flower.
Shure:  因为怡宝和农夫山泉
Shure: Because Yibao and Nongfu Spring.
Shure:  这两个我都能尝出来
Shure: I can recognize both of these.
Shure:  走吧走吧
Shure: Let's go, let's go.
Alice: 嗯好的
Alice: Okay.
Shure:  哎呦真的这咖啡
Shure: Oh man, this coffee.
Shure:  早说这个活动不喝咖啡
Shure: If I knew, I wouldn't have had coffee for this activity.
Shure:  先擦擦舌头
Shure: Wipe my tongue first.
Katrina:  擦擦舌头
Katrina: Wipe your tongue.
Jake: 擦一擦
Jake: Wipe it clean.
Alice: 这是什么
Alice: What is this?
Alice: 这是
Alice: This is...
Alice: 苏打水跟什么
Alice: Soda water with what?
Shure:  水水水水水水水
Shure: Water, water, water, water, water...
Alice: 这个不是有气泡吗
Alice: Doesn't this have bubbles?
Shure:  啊只有一杯是那个元气森林
Shure: Ah, only one cup is that Yuanqi Forest.
Shure:  其他都是普通的
Shure: The rest are just regular.
Alice: 这是要干嘛
Alice: What's this for?
Lucia: 这是
Lucia: This is...
Shure:  品鉴
Shure: Tasting.
Lucia: 品鉴不同的水
Lucia: Tasting different waters.
Jake: 好请大家请坐
Jake: Okay, everyone, please take a seat.
Jake: 各就各位
Jake: Everyone, get ready.
Jake: 齐了吗没齐
Jake: Are we all here? No, we're not.
Jake: 大家挑一个位置吧
Jake: Everyone pick a spot.
Jake: 座位也不太重要
Jake: The seats don't really matter.
Jake: 薇薇干嘛去了
Jake: Where did Tasha go?
Shure:  薇薇有点急事
Shure: Tasha had something urgent.
Jake: 哦莫急莫急
Jake: Oh, no rush, no rush.
Alice: 这个这个
Alice: This, this...
Alice: 放这吧放那边吧
Alice: Put this here, put that over there.
Tasha: 你要不坐那啊
Tasha: Why don't you sit there?
Shure:  你坐那没有想Siri
Shure: Sitting there makes you look like Siri.
Shure:  尝试一下king
Shure: Try out being the king.
Alice: 哪个要喝了吗
Alice: Which one are we drinking?
Jake: 等等一下吧
Jake: Hold on a bit.
Jake: 就是薇薇她是出不来是吧
Jake: So, Tasha can't come out, right?
Alice: 呃几分钟就好了
Alice: Uh, just a few minutes.
Jake: 好那等等她吧
Jake: Okay, let's wait for her.
Alice: 你不会要喝哪哪个的味道吧
Alice: You don't really plan to taste the difference, do you?
Shure:  是的yes
Shure: Yes, yes.
Shure:  你觉得你能尝出来吗
Shure: Do you think you can tell the difference?
Katrina:  我从来没有留意过
Katrina: I've never really paid attention.
Katrina:  就是不同矿泉水的味道
Katrina: To the taste of different mineral waters.
Shure:  你不会就忠于买哪个牌子吗
Shure: Don't you just stick to one brand?
Katrina:  不会啊随便买
Katrina: No, I just buy whatever.
Katrina:  不是哪个价格低就买哪个
Katrina: I just go for the cheapest one.
Shure:  我就不爱喝农夫山泉
Shure: I don't like Nongfu Spring.
Shure:  其他都可以
Shure: The rest are fine.
Shure:  所以农夫山泉一定能尝
Shure: So, you can definitely taste Nongfu Spring.
Shure:  然后最爱喝的是怡宝啊
Shure: And my favorite to drink is Yibao.
Alice: 对怡宝甜
Alice: Yeah, Yibao is sweet.
Shure:  对怡宝是甜
Shure: Yes, Yibao is sweet.
Shure:  农夫山泉根本不甜
Shure: Nongfu Spring is not sweet at all.
Shure:  好像怡宝是偏一点酸性
Shure: It seems like Yibao is a bit more acidic.
Shure:  说是不是那么健康
Shure: So, it's not that healthy.
Katrina:  哪个
Katrina: Which one?
Shure:  怡宝  就是它PH值
Shure: Yibao. It's about its pH level.
Katrina:  哪个水最好来着
Katrina: Which water is the best?
Shure:  娃哈哈哦
Shure: Wahaha.
Alice: 娃哈哈最啥实
Alice: Wahaha is the most what?
Shure:  实验用水都是
Shure: It's used for experiments.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 好这个
Jake: Okay, this one.
Jake: 怎么说呢
Jake: How do I put it?
Jake: 先不要说话
Jake: First, don't talk.
Jake: 然后写答案
Jake: Then write your answers.
Jake: 好可以开始
Jake: Okay, you can start.
Jake: 不要交流
Jake: Don't communicate.
Jake: 对不要
Jake: Yes, don't.
Jake: 写写写充电宝
Jake: Write, write, write power bank.
Shure:  写充电宝
Shure: Write power bank.
Jake: 上来发充电宝
Jake: Come up and hand out the power banks.
Shure:  我的充电宝真的都当手卡用
Shure: I use my power banks as hand cards.
Tasha: 只有一根笔吧
Tasha: There's only one pen, right?
Jake: 对一支笔
Jake: Yes, one pen.
Jake: 或者哈哈
Jake: Or, haha.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 我记得楼下有便签啊哎
Lucia: I remember there are sticky notes downstairs.
Jake: 对用便签也可以
Jake: Yes, you can use sticky notes.
Jake: 但是笔就这么一点
Jake: But there are only a few pens.
Jake: 我有笔我有笔
Jake: I have a pen, I have a pen.
Alice: 现在是不是可以开始尝了
Alice: Can we start tasting now?
Alice: 吧
Alice: Right?
Jake: 什么什么
Jake: What, what?
Alice: 可以开始喝了吧
Alice: Can we start drinking now?
Jake: 可以上了
Jake: You can begin.
Katrina:  一直连不上啊
Katrina: It’s not connecting.
Shure:  没开机吧
Shure: Maybe it's not turned on.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake: 很有可能
Jake: Very likely.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  你别别这么夸
Shure: Don't praise me like that.
Shure:  哈哈哈我没法接了哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha, I don't know how to respond, hahaha.
Lucia: 应该说不愧是我
Lucia: You should say "That's just like me!"
Shure:  这怎么还甜呢
Shure: Why does this taste sweet?
Shure:  不是他哎呀
Shure: It's not him, oh my!
Jake: 不准说话啊
Jake: No talking allowed!
Jake: 可以就是把握尺度啊
Jake: You can, just keep it in moderation.
Jake: 就是保证你们答案不一样
Jake: Just make sure your answers are different.
Shure:  嗯这个尝试
Shure: Hmm, let's try this.
Alice: 好像咖啡喝啥都一个味
Alice: It seems like coffee always tastes the same.
Lucia: 完了
Lucia: Oh no.
Shure:  有这个应该提前通知我们一下
Shure: You should have informed us about this earlier.
Jake: 咖啡还是得喝的
Jake: Coffee still needs to be drunk.
Jake: 对吧好
Jake: Right? Okay.
Tasha: 这瓶是矿泉水
Tasha: This bottle is mineral water.
Jake: 这应该是食堂里
Jake: This should be from the cafeteria.
Jake: 哦你找到了一些
Jake: Oh, you found some.
Lucia: 好多矿泉水
Lucia: So much mineral water.
Tasha: 这个是矿泉水
Tasha: This is mineral water.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 哈哈矿泉水
Jake: Haha, mineral water.
Jake: 对是谢彬主带来的
Jake: Yes, it was brought by Xie Binzhu.
Tasha: 你不用喝都知道
Tasha: You don't even need to taste it to know.
Jake: 好酷这个
Jake: This is so cool.
Jake: 我我们找到一些环保的方案哈哈哈
Jake: We found some eco-friendly solutions, hahaha.
Lucia: 废物利用
Lucia: Recycling waste.
Jake: 太环保了
Jake: So eco-friendly.
Tasha: 这个餐巾纸我想要一张
Tasha: I want a piece of this napkin.
Tasha: 这倒的漏出来了水好不好意思
Tasha: I accidentally spilled water, how embarrassing.
Jake: 不差了不差了
Jake: It's fine, it's fine.
Jake: 然后这边有好几支笔
Jake: And there are several pens here.
Lucia: 我是不是得用这种啊
Lucia: Should I use this one?
Lucia: 你也是可以
Lucia: You can too.
Jake: 你们就换着用
Jake: You guys can take turns using it.
Jake: 或者有没有纸
Jake: Or is there any paper?
Lucia: 这样我就可以用
Lucia: Then I can use this.
Tasha: 这这个是怎么怎么呢
Tasha: How... how do you do this?
Tasha: 怎么写编号呢
Tasha: How do you write the number?
Tasha: 哦哦123456
Tasha: Oh oh, 123456.
Jake: 对哦嗯
Jake: Oh right, yeah.
Jake: 我我我我我觉得这个有点小
Jake: I-I-I think this is a bit small.
Lucia: 他写不下啊
Lucia: It won't fit.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 底下还有这种黑纸盒吗
Lucia: Are there more of these black boxes below?
Lucia: 730以后再喝别的来
Lucia: Drink something else after 7:30.
Jake: 这样
Jake: Like this.
Lucia: Oh Jesus
Lucia: Oh Jesus.
Katrina:  随便写吧
Katrina: Just write whatever.
Shure:  你肯定先避开下一个
Shure: Make sure to avoid the next one.
Tasha: 我觉得这应该写ABCDE
Tasha: I think this should be written as ABCDE.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 其实你们有些人带着充电宝对吧
Jake: Actually, some of you have power banks, right?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 你自己
Jake: You yourself...
Lucia: 哎这样可以少写好些字对
Lucia: This way you can write fewer words, right?
Shure:  这次都不用尝就看出来了啊
Shure: This time you can tell without even tasting, huh?
Katrina:  转一个弯
Katrina: Take a turn.
Katrina:  最纯净哦
Katrina: The purest one.
Shure:  写写写编号对
Shure: Write, write, write the number.
Lucia: 有的水喝过来没记住那个味怎么办
Lucia: What if you forget the taste after drinking?
Tasha: 尝不出来啊
Tasha: Can't tell the difference.
Jake: 多尝几次
Jake: Try a few more times.
Jake: 哈哈多尝几次
Jake: Haha, try a few more times.
Lucia: 喝完了快
Lucia: Drink it up quickly.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 这么这么渴吗
Jake: Are you that thirsty?
Alice: 不是尝尝尝尝
Alice: Not tasting, just tasting.
Lucia: 刚好补充水分
Lucia: Just replenishing water.
Katrina:  交卷
Katrina: Hand it in.
Katrina:  嗯没有笔吗
Katrina: Hmm, no pen?
Shure:  3都长出来了
Shure: All three have grown.
Katrina:  整的现在
Katrina: Fix it now.
Jake: 尝出来了
Jake: Figured it out.
Katrina:  鉴酒似的
Katrina: Like wine tasting.
Lucia: 嗯可以可以
Lucia: Hmm, it's okay.
Lucia: 能写就行
Lucia: As long as you can write.
Jake: a b c d f
Jake: 我也想尝尝
Jake: I also want to try it.
Jake: 一会再尝
Jake: I'll try it later.
Jake: 我们一会再尝尝
Jake: We'll try it later.
Shure:  摸温度哈哈哈好聪明
Shure: Feeling the temperature, haha, so smart.
Tasha: 有一瓶好冰啊
Tasha: One of them is really cold.
Jake: 啊哦真的
Jake: Oh, really?
Alice: 在哪啊不是在哪洗
Alice: Where is it? I mean, where do you wash it?
Shure:  我估计应该最冰的是他
Shure: I guess the coldest one is him.
Shure:  因为他最大
Shure: Because he's the biggest.
Shure:  有没有可能
Shure: Is that possible?
Tasha: 有一瓶好冰啊
Tasha: One of them is really cold.
Alice: 哎答案写在哪啊
Alice: Hey, where's the answer written?
Katrina:  掰一下给你
Katrina: Let me break it for you.
Alice: 哦可以可以
Alice: Oh, okay, okay.
Alice: 不过我按我的顺序跟他对一下
Alice: But I'll check it against my order.
Katrina:  好这样写
Katrina: Alright, write it like this.
Alice: 这样可以
Alice: This is fine.
Alice: 这是啥呀甲
Alice: What is this, "A"?
Katrina:  拿这写也行
Katrina: You can write with this too.
Shure:  f
Shure: f
Shure:  这是f的话题
Shure: This is the topic "f".
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Right?
Jake: 我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 我乱写
Jake: I'm just writing randomly.
Tasha: 有白板笔吗
Tasha: Do we have a whiteboard marker?
Jake: 样题
Jake: Sample question.
Shure:  我绝对不能把我的一包选错
Shure: I definitely can't choose the wrong one from my pack.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  拭目以待
Katrina: Let's wait and see.
Lucia: 能从这个圆这瓶里再倒出来喝吗
Lucia: Can we pour it out from this round bottle and drink?
Shure:  疯了
Shure: Crazy.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh.
Lucia: 比较一下吗
Lucia: To compare?
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Shure:  没有空杯子
Shure: No empty cups.
Lucia: 喝完某一个就好了
Lucia: Just finish one of them.
Jake: 我们有几位已经整出来了吗感觉
Jake: Have any of us figured it out yet?
Jake: 已经交卷了
Jake: Already handed it in.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Jake: 这么牛逼
Jake: That's so awesome.
Katrina:  主要是我从来
Katrina: Mainly because I never...
Jake: 我看一看建浩老师
Jake: Let me see Mr. Jianhao's work.
Jake: 来看你的答案
Jake: Let's see your answer.
Katrina:  哈哈哈鹅
Katrina: Hahaha...
Shure:  猜
Shure: Guess.
Katrina:  主要是全不会
Katrina: Mainly because I don't know any of it.
Katrina:  就跟那种完全没学过一样
Katrina: It's like I haven't learned any of it.
Katrina:  然后哈哈哈
Katrina: And then hahaha...
Jake: 就可以替身交卷
Jake: You can just submit a substitute paper.
Shure:  都选c吧
Shure: Just choose C for all.
Shure:  那不就
Shure: Wouldn't that...
Katrina:  对啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  但是都写怡宝
Katrina: But write "Yibao" for all.
Katrina:  总有一个对的
Katrina: At least one will be right.
Lucia: 好有道理
Lucia: Makes so much sense.
Katrina:  矿泉水
Katrina: Mineral water.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 我打算都写怡宝
Lucia: I'm planning to write "Yibao" for all.
Jake: 哈哈我看看你的怡宝对不对
Jake: Haha let me see if your "Yibao" is correct.
Shure:  是不是对的
Shure: Is it correct?
Jake: 不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Shure:  你看监考是回避我的
Shure: The invigilator is avoiding me.
Alice: 给
Alice: Here.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jake: 那我还能怎么说呢
Jake: What else can I say?
Jake: 看一看
Jake: Let's see.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 怎么了
Alice: What's wrong?
Jake: 没看明白
Jake: I don't understand it.
Jake: 就是要要倒一下顺序
Jake: We need to reverse the order.
Shure:  我交卷了老师
Shure: I'm submitting my paper, teacher.
Jake: 这样吧你们你们按照这个字母12123456
Jake: How about this? Follow this sequence of letters: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Jake: 然后按照字母顺一下
Jake: And then arrange them in order.
Jake: 不然我们这个就是像选择题答案一样
Jake: Otherwise, it's just like the answers to multiple-choice questions.
Jake: 知道吧我们一会对
Jake: You know, we'll compare later.
Jake: 一会我们就会报这个
Jake: We'll report this later.
Jake: EFCD之类的
Jake: Like EFCD and so on.
Jake: 这种
Jake: This kind of thing.
Shure:  没问题
Shure: No problem.
Jake: 来写一下
Jake: Let's write it down.
Jake: 没没看明白就是
Jake: I didn't quite understand.
Jake: 交卷
Jake: Hand in the paper.
Alice: 就是一到六
Alice: Just from one to six.
Jake: 答题卡答题卡
Jake: Answer sheet, answer sheet.
Tasha: 44
Tasha: 44.
Alice: 23
Alice: 23.
Tasha: 1
Tasha: 1.
Tasha: 55
Tasha: 55.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey.
Jake: 给收卷
Jake: Collect the papers.
Lucia: 纯净水的矿泉水
Lucia: Purified mineral water.
Jake: 好收卷
Jake: Okay, collect the papers.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake: 收卷
Jake: Collect the papers.
Lucia: 完了
Lucia: Done.
Lucia: 卷子没写完
Lucia: I didn't finish the paper.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Oh no.
Katrina:  答题卡没涂
Katrina: I didn't fill in the answer sheet.
Shure:  答题卡没涂
Shure: I didn't fill in the answer sheet.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Oh no.
Jake: 不着急不着急
Jake: Don't worry, don't worry.
Jake: 再品一品
Jake: Taste it again.
Jake: 说实话农夫山泉那杯我一定选对
Jake: Honestly, I definitely picked the Nongfu Spring one.
Katrina:  这有啥区别
Katrina: What's the difference?
Shure:  农夫山泉跟他们那个确实打的不一样
Shure: Nongfu Spring and their water are definitely different.
Shure:  农夫山泉明显不甜
Shure: Nongfu Spring is clearly not sweet.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  我还有一个同学
Shure: I have a classmate.
Shure:  只要一喝农夫山泉就会拉的
Shure: Every time he drinks Nongfu Spring, he gets diarrhea.
Jake: 对对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Katrina:  太那个什么经典说娃哈哈的公子
Katrina: So classic, like Wahaha's young master.
Shure:  哈哈哈只能喝娃哈哈
Shure: Hahaha, can only drink Wahaha.
Lucia: 不好意思三五
Lucia: Sorry, thirty-five.
Tasha: 我就只能喝我就尝出来了娃哈哈的味
Tasha: I can only drink, I can taste the Wahaha flavor.
Lucia: 一个都尝不出来
Lucia: Couldn't taste any.
Katrina:  我去真的
Katrina: Oh really.
Alice: 这个可以
Alice: This one's good.
Katrina:  这一般是便利店里有
Katrina: These are usually available in convenience stores.
Katrina:  什么买哪个便宜卖哪个
Katrina: Just buy whatever is cheaper.
Lucia: 那个可以看看
Lucia: We can check that out.
Jake: 答题卡是不是都没写名字呀
Jake: Didn't anyone write their names on the answer sheets?
Jake: 谁是谁啊
Jake: Who's who?
Jake: 一会互相面面
Jake: Later we can look at each other.
Jake: 大家都知道
Jake: Everyone knows.
Jake: 大家都知道对
Jake: Everyone knows, right.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mm
Katrina:  今天我的生日
Katrina: It's my birthday today.
Shure:  批卷是吧
Shure: Grading papers, right?
Katrina:  要把这
Katrina: We need to...
Jake: 批卷准备
Jake: Prepare for grading.
Jake: 批卷
Jake: Grading.
Lucia: 这些其他能不能多选一个答案啊
Lucia: Can we choose more than one answer for these?
Lucia: 这样保证至少有对的
Lucia: That way we can ensure at least one is correct.
Jake: 可以啊可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Jake: 这个策略是可以的哈哈
Jake: This strategy works, haha.
Shure:  快递放在一楼椅子上了
Shure: The package is placed on the chair on the first floor.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Shure:  太有那个高中监考老师那味了
Shure: It really feels like a high school proctor.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 走来走去
Tasha: Walking back and forth.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  在晃悠
Shure: Wandering around.
Shure:  然后那个拖鞋还咔咔咔的声你知道吗
Shure: And those slippers making that clacking sound, you know?
Tasha: 啪啪啪
Tasha: Clack clack clack.
Jake: 然后没事看一看你们的答案
Jake: Then casually glancing at your answers.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Katrina:  然后咂一声
Katrina: And then making a sound.
Katrina:  嗯然后这个同学就慌
Katrina: And the student gets nervous.
Shure:  然后在他旁边叹口气唉唉
Shure: Then sighing right next to them, sigh sigh.
Alice: 唉
Alice: Sigh.
Jake: 再指指点点
Jake: Then pointing things out.
Jake: 这题写错了
Jake: Saying "this question is wrong".
Tasha: 点 就是不说话
Tasha: Just pointing, not saying anything.
Jake: 帮2分呵呵
Jake: Deducting 2 points, haha.
Alice: 也不当就这样
Alice: Not doing much, just pointing.
Alice: 就指点一下
Alice: Just pointing things out.
Lucia: 然后就这样吧
Jake: 好的互相p吧
Jake: 我们也不想看
Shure:  互相p照
Shure:  我天
Katrina:  我天呐天呐天呐
Shure:  真的是给外国人一些
Jake: 对
Shure:  这是我自个的
Katrina:  这这不是我的吗
Jake: 这是
Lucia: 啊写了写了
Shure:  那个我也写这个啊
Lucia: 自己认不出自己的答题卡了
Tasha: 这什么意思啊
Tasha: 看不懂
Katrina:  老铁
Katrina:  你自由我扯
Tasha: 三是a是吧
Jake: 是谁的呀
Jake: 真的是你的
Jake: It’s really yours.
Katrina:  是我的呀
Katrina: Yeah, it’s mine.
Tasha: 那他这个e写的是啥呀
Tasha: Then what does his 'e' mean?
Lucia: 那是我的哦
Lucia: That's mine.
Tasha: 一是c好行
Tasha: It's 'c', okay.
Jake: 好好来
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Alice: 公布答案
Alice: Announce the answers.
Jake: 公布答案
Jake: Announce the answers.
Jake: 一第一个是
Jake: The first one is...
Katrina:  我倒是写了
Katrina: I wrote it down.
Alice: 哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Jake: 一个是啥呀
Jake: What’s the first one?
Alice: 第一个是啥
Alice: What’s the first one?
Jake: 第一个是a
Jake: The first one is 'a'.
Jake: 哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 第一个是农夫山泉
Jake: The first one is Nongfu Spring.
Jake: 第二个是啥
Jake: What’s the second one?
Jake: 第二个是苏打水d嗯
Jake: The second one is soda water, 'd', yeah.
Shure:  这倒是能尝出来嗯
Shure: You can definitely taste that, yeah.
Jake: 第三个是百岁山
Jake: The third one is Baishui Mountain.
Katrina:  二是b第三是c
Katrina: Second is b, third is c.
Jake: c第四个是e
Jake: c, the fourth one is e.
Jake: 这个都这不能不对了
Jake: This can't be wrong now.
Jake: 第五个是娃哈哈
Jake: The fifth one is Wahaha.
Jake: 是b
Jake: It's b.
Shure:  你还给人家改
Shure: You're even changing it for them.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina:  不小心就是
Katrina: It was an accident.
Lucia: 哎呀这手控制不住
Lucia: Oh no, I couldn't control my hand.
Katrina:  ABC
Katrina: ABC.
Jake: 我是不是
Jake: Did I...
Jake: 我是不是写错了
Jake: Did I write it wrong?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 第六个是啥呀
Alice: What's the sixth one?
Katrina:  FS
Katrina: FS.
Jake: 第六个是
Jake: The sixth one is...
Jake: 第六个是娃哈哈
Jake: The sixth one is Wahaha.
Lucia: 第六个是娃
Lucia: The sixth one is Wa...
Jake: 没有第五个是怡宝
Jake: No, the fifth one is Yibao.
Jake: 第五个是怡宝
Jake: The fifth one is Yibao.
Jake: 给你们一些surprise
Jake: Giving you some surprises.
Shure:  第五是怡宝
Shure: The fifth one is Yibao.
Lucia: 所以第五个是F
Lucia: So the fifth one is F.
Jake: 第五是一对
Jake: The fifth one is correct.
Jake: 第五是f
Jake: The fifth one is F.
Lucia: 第六个是b
Lucia: The sixth one is b.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 好吧我给人家写标上答案写错了
Lucia: Okay, I wrote the wrong answer for them.
Katrina:  哎随便批吧
Katrina: Just mark it however.
Shure:  你就只错了两个
Shure: You only got two wrong.
Katrina:  真的吗纯瞎写
Katrina: Really? I was just guessing.
Katrina:  2分钟写完
Katrina: Finished in 2 minutes.
Shure:  农夫山泉和娃哈哈
Shure: Nongfu Spring and Wahaha.
Shure:  顺序反了
Shure: The order is reversed.
Shure:  剩下都是对的
Shure: Everything else is correct.
Lucia: 这是那个同学的来着
Lucia: Whose is this?
Jake: 来
Jake: Here.
Tasha: 这是谁的
Tasha: Whose is this?
Shure:  这是我的
Shure: It's mine.
Shure: This is mine.
Jake: 好这个是我们
Jake: Okay, this is ours.
Jake: 从我们从宇轩的乌鸦的考卷开始是吧
Jake: Let's start from Yuxuan's crow's test paper, shall we?
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Katrina:  3分
Katrina: 3 points.
Lucia: 刚把这些都交回去了
Lucia: Just handed all these back.
Shure:  哇哈乌鸦3分
Shure: Wow, the crow got 3 points.
Katrina:  f b这是b是对的
Katrina: F, B. This B is correct.
Katrina:  对不起批卷老师有点那个哦
Katrina: Sorry, the grading teacher is a bit, you know...
Tasha: 4分天呐
Tasha: 4 points, oh my god.
Jake: 来大家看看有没有改错
Jake: Come on, everyone, see if there's any mistake.
Jake: 呵呵呵太典了
Jake: Haha, this is so classic.
Katrina:  批卷老师批错了
Katrina: The grading teacher made a mistake.
Katrina:  然后去办公室找批卷老师要
Katrina: Then go to the office to find the grading teacher.
Jake: 乌鸦得了4分
Jake: The crow got 4 points.
Katrina:  天呐
Katrina: Oh my god.
Jake: 修硕几分啊
Jake: Shure, how many points did you get?
Jake: 你也是4分
Jake: You got 4 points too.
Shure:  但是我把怡宝选对了
Shure: But I got Yibao right.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 你选几分
Jake: How many points did you get?
Katrina:  我也是4分
Katrina: I also got 4 points.
Jake: 都是4分
Jake: All 4 points.
Shure:  呀
Shure: Yeah.
Alice: 3
Alice: 3.
Shure:  最后一个交卷
Shure: Last one to hand in.
Shure:  和第一个交卷的人答案是得分
Shure: Same score as the first one to hand in.
Shure:  这个得分一样
Shure: This score is the same.
Jake: 几分
Jake: How many points?
Katrina:  2分
Katrina: 2 points.
Jake: 2分
Jake: 2 points.
Jake: 你为什么得2分
Jake: Why did you get 2 points?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 好这是3分
Jake: Alright, this is 3 points.
Jake: 2分3分一排4分
Jake: 2 points, 3 points, a row of 4 points.
Jake: 那决胜一下
Jake: Let's have a showdown.
Lucia: 再喝一遍
Lucia: Drink it again.
Katrina:  石头剪刀
Katrina: Rock, paper, scissors.
Tasha: 他们仨
Tasha: The three of them.
Shure:  他仨
Shure: The three of them.
Jake: 怎么决胜呢
Jake: How do we determine the winner?
Katrina:  石头剪刀布
Katrina: Rock, paper, scissors.
Jake: 你们你们喝出吧
Jake: You guys, just drink it.
Jake: 你们喝出来这这这
Jake: Can you tell the difference between the three bottles of mineral water?
Jake: 3瓶矿泉4瓶矿泉水的味了吗
Jake: Do you know the taste of 3 bottles of mineral water?
Lucia: 两瓶纯净水两个矿泉水
Lucia: Two bottles of purified water and two bottles of mineral water.
Lucia: 只能看别的
Lucia: We can only look at other things.
Lucia: 大概
Lucia: Roughly.
Katrina:  这这位不是专业嘛
Katrina: Isn't he the expert?
Katrina:  他说他
Katrina: He said he is.
Shure:  我怡宝是能喝
Shure: I can drink Yibao.
Alice: 怡宝比较甜
Alice: Yibao is sweeter.
Shure:  对怡宝真的是这里面最甜的
Shure: Yeah, Yibao really is the sweetest among them.
Alice: 然后农夫山泉有一点辣嗓子
Alice: And Nongfu Spring has a bit of a spicy throat feel.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice: 有点涩然后他没有味
Alice: It's a bit astringent and has no taste.
Alice: 然后他有一点点那种
Alice: And it has a little bit of that...
Shure:  好像
Shure: Seems like...
Shure:  好像只有农夫山泉是偏碱性的
Shure: Seems like only Nongfu Spring is slightly alkaline.
Alice: 就农夫山泉不太好喝
Alice: Yeah, Nongfu Spring doesn't taste very good.
Shure:  我也觉得
Shure: I agree.
Katrina:  哦我喝出来了
Katrina: Oh, I figured it out.
Alice: 怡宝比较甜
Alice: Yibao is sweeter.
Jake: 好那这样吧我们
Jake: Alright, let's do this.
Jake: 我来看一下
Jake: Let me take a look.
Katrina:  哎不对不对不对
Katrina: Wait, no, no, no.
Katrina:  嗯农夫山泉是几啊
Katrina: Uh, which one is Nongfu Spring?
Shure:  农夫山泉
Shure: Nongfu Spring.
Shure:  农夫山泉是一
Shure: Nongfu Spring is number one.
Jake: 好这样吧
Jake: Alright, let's do this.
Jake: 我们来看一下各位手机的电量
Jake: Let's check everyone's phone battery.
Jake: 然后决定这个
Jake: And decide the final winner.
Jake: 最后的赢家
Jake: The ultimate winner.
Tasha: 我已经失败了
Tasha: I'm already out.
Shure:  我也是百分之18
Shure: Me too, 18%.
Katrina:  50
Katrina: 50%.
Lucia: 96
Lucia: 96%.
Shure:  哇
Shure: Wow.
Jake: 哇
Jake: Wow.
Lucia: 昨天晚上刚充的电
Lucia: Charged it last night.
Lucia: 早上就拔下来
Lucia: Unplugged it this morning.
Jake: 恭喜96号玩家
Jake: Congrats, player 96.
Katrina:  晚上也充了玩
Katrina: Charged and played last night.
Katrina:  玩到了50
Katrina: Played until level 50.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Jake: 好的那我们就按照这样的顺序
Jake: Alright, we will follow this order.
Jake: 96
Jake: 96.
Alice: 96
Alice: 96.
Jake: 呃 96
Jake: Uh, 96.
Jake: 先选礼物对吧
Jake: Choose a gift first, right?
Jake: 一会我们会把每个人的礼物给拿上来
Jake: Later, we will bring everyone's gifts up.
Jake: 介绍介绍
Jake: And introduce them.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  嗯我们要自己拿一下是吗
Shure: Do we take them ourselves?
Jake: 对你们自己拿上来
Jake: Yes, you bring them up yourself.
Jake: 然后我们把披萨也拿上来
Jake: And we'll bring the pizza up too.
Jake: 你们就边吃边聊吧好吧
Jake: You guys can eat and chat, okay?
Jake: 然后这个水就当边吃披萨边喝就好了
Jake: And you can drink the water while eating pizza.
Katrina:  好这是我的
Katrina: Okay, this is mine.
Jake: 这是你们的饮品
Jake: These are your drinks.
Katrina:  一天8杯水
Katrina: Eight glasses of water a day.
Lucia: 哈哈哈一天8杯水
Lucia: Hahaha, eight glasses a day.
Lucia: 这才6杯
Lucia: This is only six.
Lucia: 还差两杯
Lucia: Still missing two.
Jake: 大家把礼物拿上来吧
Jake: Everyone, bring your gifts up.
Jake: 好吧一天可是一杯也没喝呀
Jake: Okay, but I haven't even had one glass today.
Katrina:  今天可是一杯也没喝呀
Katrina: I haven't had a glass today either.
Lucia: 我看看我给里面装东西了吧
Lucia: Let me see if I put something inside.
Lucia: 别光带了个盒就搞笑了
Lucia: Don't just bring an empty box for laughs.
Shure:  没事客气了你
Shure: It's okay, no need to be polite.
Alice: 就出去倒点
Alice: Just go pour some out.
Shure:  我闻到有榴莲的披萨了
Shure: I smell durian pizza.
Jake: 我们把这个
Jake: Let's take this one.
Tasha: 不是这个
Tasha: Not this one.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Tasha: 没事不是
Tasha: It's okay, not this one.
Jake: 哪个
Jake: Which one?
Lucia: 这水把它掺一块
Lucia: Mix this water together.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then...
Tasha: 卖苏打水和元气森林
Tasha: Selling soda and Genki Forest drinks.
Lucia: 呃和元气森林已经喝完了
Lucia: Uh, we already finished the Genki Forest drinks.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 这样我能节约点空间
Lucia: This way I can save some space.
Lucia: 给他两杯合一杯
Lucia: Combine two cups into one.
Katrina:  磕
Katrina: Got it.
Jake: 对都喝吧都
Jake: Yeah, drink them all.
Jake: 然后这个披萨大家一起摆一摆
Jake: Then let's arrange this pizza together.
Alice: 哎不得先交换吗
Alice: Hey, shouldn't we exchange first?
Alice: 先交换
Alice: Exchange first.
Jake: 边吃边
Jake: Eat while we chat.
Jake: 边吃边聊
Jake: Eat and chat.
Lucia: 本餐厅招募信息如下
Lucia: Here's the restaurant recruitment info.
Jake: pizza Tuesday pizza first day
Jake: Pizza Tuesday, pizza first day.
Tasha: 榴莲的在这个箱子里
Tasha: The durian one is in this box.
Tasha: 啊哎
Tasha: Ah, hey.
Lucia: 怎么这么多啊
Lucia: Why so many?
Lucia: 还有小食是吗
Lucia: Are there snacks too?
Katrina:  鸡哥
Katrina: Chicken bro.
Lucia: 这是小龙虾味
Lucia: This is crayfish flavor.
Katrina:  我好想吃小龙虾
Katrina: I really want to eat crayfish.
Lucia: 那可以把小龙虾摆的靠那边一点
Lucia: Then you can put the crayfish over there a bit.
Lucia: 我没看错吧
Lucia: Am I seeing this right?
Lucia: 上面写的好像是小龙虾
Lucia: It seems to say crayfish on it.
Tasha: 这个和这个一样
Tasha: This one is the same as that one.
Tasha: 放到这哎
Tasha: Put it here, hey.
Jake: 这个是一样的吗
Jake: Are these the same?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 照烧牛肉
Lucia: Teriyaki beef.
Lucia: 哦我以前很喜欢吃这个味
Lucia: Oh, I used to love this flavor.